Tasha: 灵尊者灵魂核心获得两经验而不是经验
Tasha: The Spirit Lord's soul core gains two experience instead of experience.
Tasha: 如果战斗社保将额外获得3经验
Tasha: If the battle is social security, it will gain an extra 3 experience.
Tasha: 如果不存在
Tasha: If it doesn't exist,
Tasha: 一肥或二肥
Tasha: one fat or two fat.
Tasha: 什么意思
Tasha: What does that mean?
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Hey.
Tasha: 3级
Tasha: Level 3.
Tasha: 要3级然后走连败
Tasha: You need to be level 3 and then go for a losing streak.
Jake:开工吧
Jake: Let's get started.
Jake:上班了上班了
Jake: Time to work, time to work.
Jake:拆快递 2楼可能得收拾收拾
Jake: Unpack the delivery. The second floor might need some tidying up.
Jake:你们今天做狗吗
Jake: Are you guys working on dogs today?
Jake:今天看狗吗
Jake: Watching dogs today?
Lucia: 平时可以做
Lucia: Usually we can do it.
Lucia: 到底是做狗还是看狗啊
Lucia: Are we making dogs or watching dogs?
Jake:都可以做
Jake: We can do both.
Jake:可以看看狗
Jake: We can watch dogs.
Jake:要不我们建立一些逻辑吧
Jake: How about we establish some logic first?
Jake:作为一个
Jake: As a...
Jake:建立一些年纪
Jake: Establish some age.
Jake:我们先看狗
Jake: Let's watch dogs first.
Jake:然后按照狗去做狗
Jake: Then follow the dogs to make dogs.
Lucia: 建立逻辑是替人
Lucia: Establishing logic is for replacing people.
Jake:替人好
Jake: Replacing people is good.
Katrina: 那就是先小说看一点狗的款式
Katrina: So we first look at some dog styles.
Katrina: 然后开始选择
Katrina: Then start choosing.
Katrina: 然后再做
Katrina: Then make it.
Lucia: 可以
Lucia: Okay.
Lucia: 我需要一支笔
Lucia: I need a pen.
Jake: 做狗它们会有一个一条纸板
Jake: When making dogs, they will have a cardboard.
Lucia:  就是只要只要能只要能画个大概就行
Lucia: As long as you can draw a rough outline, it's fine.
Jake:然后把纸板变成狗
Jake: Then turn the cardboard into a dog.
Lucia: 头暂时还不需要过多考虑
Lucia: The head doesn't need too much consideration for now.
Lucia: 哦   点
Lucia: Oh, point.
Tasha: 三阶段就能卡着利息升8级我靠
Tasha: By stage three, you can level up to 8 by holding interest, damn.
Lucia: 在我的眼镜突然被转歪的时候
Lucia: When my glasses suddenly get tilted,
Lucia: AI会不会以为地震了
Lucia: will the AI think it's an earthquake?
Jake:那可能地震频率过高
Jake: Maybe the earthquake frequency is too high.
Lucia: 是不是个好问题
Lucia: Is that a good question?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia: 也没有很经常吧
Lucia: Not very often, right?
Lucia: 我只是刚才突然转到线了而已
Lucia: I just suddenly got online just now.
Jake:那没电了
Jake: Oh, it's out of power.
Jake:确实和地震
Jake: It does feel like an earthquake.
Lucia: 我需要一根笔老板
Lucia: I need a pen, boss.
Jake:什么笔
Jake: What kind of pen?
Lucia: 随便什么笔
Lucia: Any pen will do.
Lucia: 能在纸箱上面画出来线就行
Lucia: As long as it can draw a line on the cardboard.
Jake:噢
Jake: Oh.
Jake:还有我们之前买的彩笔是还没到吗
Jake: Are the colored pens we ordered before still not here?
Lucia: 好我们已经实现无纸化工作了
Lucia: Well, we've gone paperless now.
Lucia: 现在没有笔是吧
Lucia: So there are no pens, right?
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Jake:是没到是吧
Jake: They haven't arrived yet, right?
Shure: 我们要不要臆想出来一只纸狗
Shure: Should we imagine a paper dog?
Lucia: 因为我害怕一直用这白板笔
Lucia: Because I'm afraid if I keep using this whiteboard marker...
Lucia: 给他用没墨了
Lucia: It will run out of ink.
Jake:嗯买买买
Jake: Alright, buy more, buy more.
Jake:所以没到还是还是怎么回事
Jake: So, have they arrived or not?
Lucia: 什么没到
Lucia: What hasn't arrived?
Jake:之前买的这个笔吗
Jake: The pens we ordered before?
Katrina: 彩笔刚到
Katrina: The colored pens just arrived.
Jake:彩笔
Jake: The colored pens?
Katrina: 刚到刚到菜鸟驿站
Katrina: They just arrived at the pickup point.
Katrina: 刚到菜鸟驿站
Jake:哦那就还能领是吧
Jake: Oh, so we can still pick them up?
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Jake:今天还能
Jake: Today we can.
Jake:今天就能拿到了
Jake: We can get them today.
Jake:催他们一下
Jake: Hurry them up a bit.
Tasha: 墨菲流丝带来娜拉可西
Tasha: Murphy's Law strikes again.
Lucia: 雨轩有那种普通的写字的笔
Lucia: Yuxuan has those regular writing pens.
Lucia: 但是我感觉往完了纸上可能有点
Lucia: But I feel like they might be a bit...
Lucia: 有点细好做标记的话所以
Lucia: A bit thin for marking, so...
Jake:那就去取快递
Jake: Then go pick up the package.
Tasha: 他虽然能上7个人
Tasha: Even though it can hold 7 people...
Tasha: 但是的卡牌里面的那个概率还是那个
Tasha: The probability in the card deck is still...
Tasha: 那个等级概率啊
Tasha: The level probability, yeah.
Jake:走把二楼给收拾收拾给你们跳舞
Jake: Let's go, clean up the second floor so you can dance.
Shure: 二楼有什么
Shure: What's on the second floor?
Jake:二楼有饺子
Jake: There are dumplings on the second floor.
Tasha: 哎呀你这连胜没吃到呀
Tasha: Oh no, you missed the winning streak.
Lucia: 这个怎么做呀
Lucia: How do you do this?
Katrina: 特别简单
Katrina: It's really simple.
Katrina: 就是
Katrina: It's just...
Lucia: 我们需要用到的是哪些呀
Lucia: What do we need to use?
Katrina: 就这一套
Katrina: Just this set.
Katrina: 嗯下面是海绵
Katrina: Hmm, the bottom part is a sponge.
Katrina: 然后垫一层这个然后垫一层纸
Katrina: Then you put a layer of this, then a layer of paper.
Katrina: 垫一层这个垫一层这个
Katrina: Layer this, layer this.
Katrina: 这是干燥板
Katrina: This is a drying board.
Katrina: 然后把它包起来就好了
Katrina: Then wrap it up, and it's done.
Katrina: 然后各种花你可以上网看一下
Katrina: You can find all kinds of flowers online.
Katrina: 有的人建议是弄花瓣
Katrina: Some people suggest using petals.
Katrina: 像这种小花就可以直接压
Katrina: For small flowers like these, you can press them directly.
Katrina: 大花的话像我那天压出来效果不好
Katrina: For big flowers, the effect wasn't good when I pressed them the other day.
Katrina: 我这次打算把它这样侧着压
Katrina: This time, I plan to press them sideways.
Katrina: 看看会不会好一点
Katrina: Let's see if it works better.
Katrina: 我上次这样压你知道吗
Katrina: You know, I pressed it like this last time.
Katrina: 这样压确实这样散了
Katrina: When I pressed it like this, it scattered.
Lucia: 哦中间这个就比他们高很多
Lucia: Oh, the middle part is much taller than the others.
Katrina: 芍药的话我是扒了外面的
Katrina: For peonies, I peeled off the outer parts.
Katrina: 因为他这太立体了
Katrina: Because it's too three-dimensional.
Katrina: 这样压不了
Katrina: You can't press it like this.
Katrina: 就扒了外面的粉色大片
Katrina: So I peeled off the big pink outer petals.
Lucia: 或者能不能把这里给他修剪
Lucia: Or maybe we could trim this part?
Katrina: 可以他们说也可以
Katrina: Yeah, they said you could do that too.
Katrina: 也可以把压这一块
Katrina: You can also press this part.
Katrina: 这个可以放网上教程
Katrina: You can find tutorials online.
Katrina: 我感觉我也不太熟悉
Katrina: I feel like I'm not that familiar with it either.
Lucia: 这个是怎么放的看看你的
Lucia: How do you place this? Let's see yours.
Katrina: 最下面一层海绵这样子
Katrina: The bottom layer is a sponge, like this.
Lucia: 先这个对吧
Lucia: This first, right?
Lucia: 然后放一层海绵
Lucia: Then a layer of sponge.
Katrina: 干燥板放一层干燥板然后放一层纸
Katrina: A drying board, then a layer of paper.
Lucia: 这个白的的东西这里面好像没有
Lucia: This white thing doesn't seem to be in here.
Katrina: 这里面好像没有哎
Katrina: Yeah, it doesn't seem to be in here.
Katrina: 噢那个在那
Katrina: Oh, it's over there.
Katrina: 谢谢
Katrina: Thanks.
Lucia: 然后就放纸
Lucia: Then just put the paper.
Lucia: 纸上就放纸
Lucia: Just put the paper on the paper.
Lucia: 然后就可以放花了啊
Lucia: Then you can place the flowers.
Lucia: 所以就是这里面可以垫好几层海绵
Lucia: So, you can layer several pieces of sponge inside.
Lucia: 放好几层花
Lucia: And put several layers of flowers.
Katrina: 嗯嗯
Katrina: Mm-hmm.
Lucia: 这张有点有点折的
Lucia: This one is a bit crumpled.
Lucia: 都有点折
Lucia: They're all a bit crumpled.
Lucia: 就这样吧
Lucia: Let's leave it like this.
Jake:没亮又化了
Jake: It melted without lighting up.
Lucia: sorry 我成功把它重合成一个非常短的视频
Lucia: Sorry, I successfully merged it into a very short video.
Jake:好好那你再开一下
Jake: Okay, then open it again.
Jake:再来一个再来一个
Jake: Do another one, do another one.
Jake:有快递拆吗
Jake: Any packages to open?
Jake:没有那下午干什么
Jake: No? Then what to do in the afternoon?
Jake:什么都可以
Jake: Anything is fine.
Jake:有快递拆吗
Jake: Any packages to open?
Jake:那下午干什么
Jake: Then what to do in the afternoon?
Tasha: 卡拉OK
Tasha: Karaoke.
Jake:打金铲铲
Jake: Play TFT.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:你应该有很多花要压
Jake: You probably have a lot of flowers to press.
Jake:然后还需要有人帮你压花
Jake: And you'll need someone to help you press the flowers.
Jake:嗯对
Jake: Mm, right.
Lucia: 我正在试图压花
Lucia: I'm trying to press the flowers.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Jake:二楼要不有空收拾收拾
Jake: Maybe we can tidy up the second floor when we have time.
Jake:走
Jake: Let's go.
Alice:小狗在哪
Alice: Where's the puppy?
Jake:狗在
Jake: The dog is here.
Jake:你是活狗还是死狗
Jake: Are you a live dog or a dead dog?
Tasha: 哈哈我天哪
Tasha: Haha, oh my god.
Jake:活活哈哈哈活狗
Jake: Alive, hahaha, alive dog.
Katrina: 咖啡店那个吗
Katrina: The one at the cafe?
Jake:对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:活狗可以看一看
Jake: You can check out the live dog.
Jake:咖啡店我我没去过
Jake: I haven't been to the cafe.
Jake:据说200米很近
Jake: They say it's just 200 meters, very close.
Lucia: 我们可以先用自己的理念构思一只狗
Lucia: We can first use our own ideas to design a dog.
Jake:嗯对
Jake: Yeah, right.
Jake:然后看画的狗和真正的狗长不长
Jake: And then see if the drawn dog looks like the real dog.
Jake:像不像
Jake: Does it look like it?
Lucia: 白马非马
Lucia: A white horse is not a horse.
Jake:走我们把二楼收拾收拾
Jake: Come on, let's tidy up the second floor.
Jake:没没事的兄弟姐妹们
Jake: It's all good, guys.
Tasha: 啊可以
Tasha: Oh, okay.
Lucia: 啊啊啊这这朵枯萎了
Lucia: Ah, this flower has wilted.
Lucia: 好消息是我的芍药开始想开了
Lucia: The good news is my peony is starting to bloom.
Lucia: 逐渐想开
Lucia: Gradually blooming.
Lucia: 文本压那一朵呢
Lucia: What about that one that's being pressed by the text?
Lucia: 我又把我手机放哪了
Lucia: Where did I put my phone again?
Katrina: 所以那个衣服怎么说来着
Katrina: So, what about the clothes?
Katrina: 衣服
Katrina: The clothes.
Tasha: 说是租吧
Tasha: They said to rent them.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Katrina: 线下租
Katrina: Rent offline?
Tasha: 线上也可以
Tasha: Online works too.
Katrina: 那线上要下单不
Katrina: Should we place an order online?
Tasha: 我看了一家了
Tasha: I've checked out a place.
Katrina: 请你发群里吧
Katrina: Please share it in the group.
Katrina: 能让大家报一下尺码
Katrina: So everyone can provide their sizes.
Lucia: 这花是它
Lucia: Is this flower...
Lucia: 准备谢了还是它没没开
Lucia: About to wilt, or has it not bloomed yet?
Katrina: 应该快要谢了
Katrina: It should be about to wilt.
Lucia: 但它里面就是里面的花瓣有好硬
Lucia: But the petals inside are still quite firm.
Lucia: 要不这个吧
Lucia: How about this one?
Lucia: 这个花形
Lucia: This flower shape.
Lucia: 哈哈哈圆一点
Lucia: Haha, it's a bit rounder.
Nicous: 这你都能输啊
Nicous: You lost even this?
Tasha: 我打的是连败啊
Tasha: I'm on a losing streak.
Tasha: 你看我五级星3尊者
Tasha: Look, I'm a level 5 star, rank 3.
Tasha: 一回合可以吃10个金币
Tasha: I can earn 10 gold coins in one round.
Nicous: 五级星被你搞基了
Nicous: You've messed up the level 5 star.
Tasha: 靠我也五级星
Tasha: Damn, I'm also level 5 star.
Tasha: 你看你强度怎么上这么高
Tasha: How did your strength get so high?
Nicous: 我搞个够吧
Nicous: I just kept upgrading.
Nicous: 我就五级星
Nicous: I'm just level 5 star.
Tasha: 哎你猜一个一一一
Tasha: Hey, guess what, one one one...
Tasha: 才从一开始
Tasha: Just from the start...
Tasha: 有什么好伤心的
Tasha: What's there to be sad about?
Tasha: 就相当于是一个装备拆卸器
Tasha: It's basically an equipment remover.
Tasha: 你把它放到备战席上
Tasha: You place it on the preparation bench.
Tasha: 他装备就掉下来了
Tasha: The equipment will fall off.
Tasha: 没有啊你97滴血
Tasha: No, you have 97 health points.
Tasha: 你转啥都行啊
Tasha: You can switch to anything.
Tasha: 你可以先先用五极星玩个三连
Tasha: You can play a triple combo with the five-star.
Tasha: 玩到你看你这不是还要几个回合
Tasha: Play a few more rounds, you see, you still have a few rounds left.
Tasha: 还要五个回合才能收菜嘛
Tasha: You need five more rounds to harvest.
Tasha: 你收了一波菜之后你再转嘛
Tasha: After you harvest, then you can switch.
Tasha: 转啥都行
Tasha: Switch to anything you want.
Tasha: 不就是我吗
Tasha: Isn't it just me?
Tasha: 还有第二
Tasha: There's no second.
Tasha: 赛娜
Tasha: Senna.
Tasha: 你多少级了
Tasha: What level are you?
Tasha: 玩赛娜
Tasha: Play Senna.
Tasha: 好吧 6级可以玩
Tasha: Okay, level 6 is playable.
Tasha: 哎呦这人傻逼吧
Tasha: Oh my, is this person dumb?
Tasha: 为什么他打不过我呀
Tasha: Why can't he beat me?
Jake:听说你把心如干蒙了
Jake: I heard you surprised Xinru.
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Jake:是的
Jake: Yes.
Jake:你你现在是第几
Jake: What rank are you now?
Tasha: 我现在是这个名字
Tasha: I'm under this name.
Tasha: 但是其实我只是一直在打连败的
Tasha: But actually, I've been constantly losing.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:心如现在还是短暂的第一名是吧
Jake: Xinru is still temporarily first place, right?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Tasha: 他也想连败的
Tasha: He wants to keep losing too.
Lucia: 他浅浅的破防了
Lucia: He's slightly broken down.
Tasha: 他想要连败
Tasha: He wants to keep losing.
Tasha: 我也想要连败
Tasha: I want to keep losing too.
Tasha: 但他连败不过我
Tasha: But he can't lose more than me.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:笑笑死我了
Jake: This is hilarious.
Jake:这个很难解释
Jake: This is hard to explain.
Jake:不知道怎么怎么解释
Jake: I don't know how to explain it.
Katrina: 哈哈哈看下小红书教程吧
Katrina: Haha, let's check Xiaohongshu tutorials.
Katrina: 我也是瞎做
Katrina: I just made things up.
Lucia: 看了但是感觉就这种厚的花
Lucia: I watched them, but it seems like these thick flowers...
Lucia: 就是很容易会缩
Lucia: ...are prone to shrink.
Lucia: 我在想你有什么办法让它不缩
Lucia: I was wondering if you have any way to keep it from shrinking.
Katrina: 那你就可以压这种小花这样一放
Katrina: Then you can press this kind of small flower and place it like this.
Lucia: 对对那种小花好压一下
Lucia: Yes, yes, press those small flowers.
Lucia: 但我这个小的感觉它现在开的很旺盛
Lucia: But this small one feels like it's blooming so vigorously right now.
Lucia: 我有点舍不得把它剪下来
Lucia: I feel a bit reluctant to cut it down.
Lucia: 残忍的咔咔
Lucia: It's cruel to snip it off.
Jake:剪一半
Jake: Just cut half of it.
Lucia: 还可以这样
Lucia: You can do that?
Lucia: 那剩下可以是可以啊
Lucia: Then the remaining part is still fine, right?
Lucia: 但那剩下的一半就会很孤单
Lucia: But the remaining half will be very lonely.
Katrina: 但我这卖不出去啊
Katrina: But I can't sell it like this.
Lucia: 没事我们又不用真货币
Lucia: It's okay, we're not using real money anyway.
Lucia: 而且
Lucia: Besides,
Lucia: 你接下来这个肯定会做的非常成功的
Lucia: Your next one will definitely be a big success.
Lucia: 第一次那个只是试验品
Lucia: The first one was just a test.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake:哎对齐一下不
Jake: Hey, should we align it?
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Huh?
Katrina: 你买那个钟
Katrina: Did you buy that clock?
Jake:就是每一帧都知道时间对不对
Jake: It lets you know the time for each frame, right?
Jake:就是可以测试用
Jake: It can be used for testing.
Jake:其实每一帧都是有时间
Jake: Actually, each frame has a timestamp.
Jake:就是对一下
Jake: Just need to align it.
Lucia: 理论上说拍电影是应该这样的
Lucia: In theory, making movies should be like that.
Lucia: 不过我鉴于我们这个不是电影所以
Lucia: But considering this isn't a movie, so...
Jake:哎你看过的对吧
Jake: Hey, you watched it, right?
Tasha: 看过了嗯
Tasha: Yeah, I did.
Lucia: 我觉得就他吧
Lucia: I think he's the one.
Lucia: 撕下来
Lucia: Tear it off.
Tasha: 我打不过你
Tasha: I can't beat you.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Nicous: 刚刚你才赢的
Nicous: You just won earlier.
Tasha: 你赢不是好吗
Tasha: Isn't it good that you won?
Tasha: 你看我打不过你
Tasha: See, I can't beat you.
Tasha: 怎么样
Tasha: How about that?
Jake:你们两个人只能交锋一次是吗
Jake: You two can only face each other once, right?
Nicous: 她这么说我破防了
Nicous: She said that, and it got to me.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake:骂游戏了
Jake: Game over.
Lucia: 我说他浅浅的破防哈哈哈
Lucia: I said he barely got to you, hahaha.
Nicous: 她套我话 就是你给我说撸把撸把
Jake:哈
Nicous: 撸把没关系 可以玩
Tasha: 可以玩
Tasha: 哈哈你看你还在第一名呢
Tasha: 这不是一个好兆头吗
Nicous: 哇靠 你刚拆我背景 当狗插
Nicous: 开玩笑
Tasha: 哎我刚刚也被人破防了一次
Tasha: 好吧我到现在才六几名
Nicous: 还好 是哪个人
Nicous: 我给他
Tasha: 叫蛰伏他已经走了
Nicous: 我草
Lucia: 浅浅的观摩下
Katrina: 我这一层是厚的
Katrina: 之前压的花瓣
Jake:我也要喝
Katrina: 这一层试验品
Tasha: 你几级啊 你六级
Tasha: What level are you? Level 6?
Tasha: 你知道我要上10级了吗马上
Tasha: Do you know I'm about to reach level 10 soon?
Tasha: 马上哈哈
Tasha: Very soon, haha.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha!
Jake:上面桌子搬完了吗
Jake: Did you finish moving the tables upstairs?
Shure: 擦完了
Shure: Yeah, wiped them clean.
Katrina: 狗你得
Katrina: The dog, you need to...
俢硕：狗在咖啡店
Shure: The dog is at the coffee shop.
Katrina: 对它还没进行社会化训练
Katrina: Yeah, it hasn't had any socialization training yet.
Shure: 对它会咬你
Shure: Yup, it might bite you.
Katrina: 对啊但它没长啥牙
Katrina: Yeah, but it doesn't have much teeth yet.
Katrina: 没事两三个月
Katrina: It's fine, just two or three months.
Katrina: 小编沐浴哥是咖啡色啊
Katrina: The editor, Bath Brother, is brown.
Lucia: 好可爱哦
Lucia: So cute!
Katrina: 是很可爱超可爱
Katrina: Yeah, super cute!
Katrina: 是啊但是我忘了是左拐还是右拐
Katrina: Yeah, but I forgot if it's a left turn or right turn.
Katrina: 哦不对
Katrina: Oh, wait.
Katrina: 好像是我们这
Katrina: I think it's over here.
Katrina: 出来以后
Katrina: After we come out...
Katrina: 往哪拐
Katrina: Which way do we turn?
Katrina: 反正走
Katrina: Anyway, let’s go.
Katrina: 完全不需要
Katrina: We totally don’t need it.
Katrina: 那店主很佛系
Katrina: The shop owner is so chill.
Tasha: 可以
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 哼
Tasha: Hmph.
Tasha: 别说是我了
Tasha: Don't say it was me.
Tasha: 呵
Tasha: Heh.
Tasha: 不是吧
Tasha: No way.
Tasha: 啊sir
Tasha: Oh, sir.
Tasha: 用点力啊
Tasha: Use some force.
Tasha: 哦靠居然赢了
Tasha: Oh wow, you actually won.
Katrina: 嗯这花怎么会有黏黏的东西
Katrina: Hmm, why is this flower sticky?
Katrina: 这是还有什么声音
Katrina: And what’s that sound?
Katrina: 你可以先学
Katrina: You can learn first.
Tasha: 狠狠把他暴打了
Tasha: Beat him up hard.
Tasha: 现在开始
Tasha: Starting now.
Katrina: 他下来了呵
Katrina: He’s coming down, heh.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha.
俢硕：人家不爆杀你嘛
Shure: They didn’t go all out on you.
Shure: 随便杀他装备都没上呢
Shure: They killed you casually, and you weren’t even equipped.
Shure: 略施小计就把你玩的团团转谢彬竹
Shure: Just a little trick and they had you spinning in circles, Xie Binzhu.
Shure: 你就是这样被女人玩弄的
Shure: That’s how you get played by women.
Shure: 是不是
Shure: Isn’t it?
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Tasha: 哎就唱给你吧
Tasha: Fine, I’ll sing it for you.
Katrina: 你最后一天啥活动来着
Katrina: What's your last day's activity?
Katrina: 你怎么不用干活呢
Katrina: Why aren’t you working?
Tasha: 哎搞点
Tasha: Ah, do something.
Shure: 我最后一天什么活动
Shure: My last day’s activity?
Shure: 我是一个
Shure: I am a...
Katrina: 是每个人都要有个ID啊
Katrina: Everyone needs to have an ID.
Lucia: 我想看看这个
Lucia: I want to see this.
Lucia: 这个这个
Lucia: This, this.
Lucia: 比如说这层放完剩下再放一层纸是吗
Lucia: Like, after this layer, put another layer of paper, right?
Katrina: 对
Katrina: Yes.
Katrina: 再放一层干燥板
Katrina: Then put a dry board.
Katrina: 再放一层纸
Katrina: Then another layer of paper.
俢硕：我我是建立这个经济体系的人嘛
Shure: I’m the one who established this economic system.
Shure: 你忘记了吗
Shure: Did you forget?
Katrina: 哦哦
Katrina: Oh, right.
Shure: 我的唯一任务就是把货币做出来
Shure: My only task is to make the currency.
Katrina: 货币已经买了
Katrina: The currency has already been bought.
Shure: OK解决解决
Shure: OK, let's solve it.
Shure: 伟大无需多言
Shure: Greatness doesn't need many words.
Jake:落地了是吧
Jake: It's implemented, right?
Jake:伟大的构想
Jake: Great idea.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 你知道我国第一个货币叫做什么吗
Shure: Do you know what our country's first currency was called?
Shure: 让我
Shure: Let me...
Alice:修币
Alice: Shure coin.
Shure: 那出出现在哪个哪个朝代
Shure: And in which dynasty did it appear?
Jake:包比比
Jake: Bao Bi Bi.
Tasha: 你是什么东西
Tasha: What are you talking about?
Tasha: 怎么还在这
Tasha: Why are you still here?
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey.
Jake:包比我那个狗狗币
Jake: Bao Bi, my dogecoin.
Shure: 宋代的骄子
Shure: A pride of the Song Dynasty.
Shure: 是我国第一个出现的纸币
Shure: It was the first paper currency in our country.
Lucia: 放哪去了
Lucia: Where did you put it?
Jake:哪真的呀这是
Jake: Is this for real?
Alice:但我没见过娇子见过饺子
Alice: But I've never seen Jiaozi, only dumplings.
Katrina: 还有一个板你想做也可以做
Katrina: There's one more board, you can make it if you want.
Lucia: 对刚才
Lucia: Yeah, just now.
Katrina: 来吧用掉吧
Katrina: Come on, use it.
Lucia: 明明记得刚才在这边有
Lucia: I clearly remember there was one here just now.
Tasha:  就这样吧
Tasha: Let's just leave it like this.
Katrina: 夹汉堡包
Katrina: A burger.
Tasha: 我觉得利桑卓在这个版本最厉害
Tasha: I think Lissandra is the strongest in this version.
Tasha: 5费卡里面
Tasha: Among the 5-cost cards.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 那刀妹和猴子的话就猴子厉害点吧
Tasha: Between Irelia and Wukong, Wukong is stronger.
Lucia: 哎呦太厚了
Lucia: Oh, it's too thick.
Katrina: 唉哟我直接用新的吧
Katrina: Oh, I'll just use a new one.
Tasha: 拿个什么呢
Tasha: What should I take?
Tasha: 哒哒哒
Tasha: Da da da.
Lucia: 太厚了的话我改变一下策略
Lucia: If it's too thick, I'll change my strategy.
Tasha: 就抢个无敌2把
Tasha: I'll just grab an invincible 2.
Tasha: 这把我追
Tasha: This round, I'll chase.
Nicous: 我草
Nicous: Damn.
Tasha: 我靠你到底要什么你说嘛
Tasha: Damn, what do you want exactly, just say it.
Nicous: 都可以
Nicous: Anything's fine.
Tasha: 你可以拿第二的
Tasha: You can take second place.
Tasha: 我可以把第二的位置让给你牌给你
Tasha: I can give you the second place spot.
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh.
Shure: 你等他快三星5费的时候你就点了
Shure: When he’s almost at three-star level 5, you click it.
Nicous: 肯定点
Nicous: Definitely click it.
Nicous: 不能爽啦
Nicous: No way he can enjoy this.
Jake:谢彬竹还能拿个第二啊
Jake: Xie Binzhu can still get second place?
Jake:这么牛逼
Jake: That’s impressive.
Shure: 说实话
Shure: Honestly.
Shure: 其实其他6个应该都是人机
Shure: The other 6 are probably all bots.
Nicous: 还真是
Nicous: That's actually true.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Tasha: 所以输不过他们
Tasha: So you can’t lose to them.
Tasha: 你知道吗
Tasha: You know?
Tasha:  我不要了
Tasha: I give up.
Shure: 不是所以他一个人类都没有几百
Shure: So, he's the lowest among humans.
Shure: 他就是人类中的倒数第一
Shure: He's the last among humans.
俢硕：啊
Shure: Ah.
Tasha: 就打我怎么啦
Tasha: Why are you targeting me?
Jake:它就是白光
Jake: It’s just a white light.
Nicous: 你能不能打过别人
Nicous: Can you beat anyone else?
Tasha: 我谁都打得过
Tasha: I can beat anyone.
Nicous: 那我直接点
Nicous: Then I'll click it.
Tasha: 不你为什么不往第二名
Tasha: No, why not go for second place?
Nicous: 没有区别
Nicous: There's no difference.
Nicous: 第一第二和第三有什么区别你说直接点
Nicous: What's the difference between first, second, and third place? Just click it.
Tasha: 哈哈干嘛呀
Tasha: Haha, what are you doing?
Tasha: 1只两只3只5只
Tasha: One, two, three, five...
Tasha: 这个还差4只
Tasha: This one is four short.
Tasha:  这个呢
Tasha: How about this one?
Shure: 什么都想追
Shure: You want to chase everything.
Jake:你好贪啊
Jake: You’re so greedy.
Tasha:  哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Shure: 你什么东西
Shure: What’s your deal?
Tasha: 这个不追了
Tasha: I’m not chasing this one.
Tasha: 就追你们几吧
Tasha: Just chasing a few of yours.
Tasha: 这个不追了
Tasha: Not chasing this one.
Tasha: 你你要一下
Tasha: You, you take one.
Tasha: 你也不要了
Tasha: You don't want it either.
Tasha: 会有几个了
Tasha: How many do we have?
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh
Tasha: 还差两个会
Tasha: Still need two more
Tasha: 还差几个
Tasha: How many more?
Nicous: 你要会是吧
Nicous: You need more, right?
Nicous: 我的会呢
Nicous: Where's mine?
Tasha: 会还差两个
Tasha: We still need two more
Nicous: 我这边刷到一个现在两个
Nicous: I found one, now we need two
Tasha: 无敌2 无敌2
Tasha: Invincible 2, Invincible 2
Tasha: 还差3个会
Tasha: Still need three more
Tasha: 会还差两个
Tasha: Still need two more
Tasha: 你也不追了
Tasha: You're not chasing anymore?
Tasha: 哎三星乌迪尔了
Tasha: Hey, three-star Udyr
Nicous: 谁啊
Nicous: Who?
Tasha: 就这样我等等呀
Tasha: Just like that, I'll wait
Shure: 没有那个是镜像过来的
Shure: No, that was mirrored
Tasha: 真的假的
Tasha: Really?
Shure: 你不给他装这个了吗
Shure: Aren't you going to equip him with this?
Tasha: 哎呦我靠
Tasha: Oh my god
Tasha: 不是我装的
Tasha: It wasn't me who equipped it
Tasha: 这是神器变的
Tasha: It turned into an artifact
俢硕：啊
Shure: Huh?
Tasha: 随便拿一个东西就你吧
Tasha: Just grab something, it's up to you
Shure: what's this
Shure: What's this?
Shure: bomb has been planted是吧
Shure: Bomb has been planted, right?
Shure: 炸弹已经安放
Shure: The bomb has been planted
Tasha: 唉好难追啊
Tasha: It's so hard to chase
Tasha:  两格什么东西
Tasha: What's with the two slots?
Katrina: 你做那小狗呗
Katrina: You make that little dog
Katrina: 你帮他做那个小狗
Katrina: Help him make that little dog
Tasha: 我刚不是差两张吗
Tasha: Didn't I just need two more cards?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Tasha: 我把一只两星的卖了
Tasha: I sold a two-star one
Tasha: 在干嘛哈哈哈
Tasha: What are you doing, hahaha
Nicous: 你把它们都卖了你就不能给我
Nicous: You sold them all, you couldn't give them to me?
Shure: 教教我这个怎么做
Shure: Teach me how to do this
Katrina: 这就是汉堡包
Katrina: This is a burger
Shure: 不是
Shure: No
Katrina: 是的
Katrina: Yes, it is
俢硕：夹花
Shure: Ham sandwich
Katrina: 做狗谁不会
Katrina: Who doesn't know how to be a dog?
Shure: 他说他习惯了做狗
Shure: He said he's used to being a dog.
Katrina: 做狗谁不会
Katrina: Who doesn't know how to be a dog?
Katrina: 哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Lucia: 做狗谁不会哈哈哈
Lucia: Who doesn't know how to be a dog? Hahaha
Katrina: 今天要有太阳就好
Katrina: It would be nice if it was sunny today.
Tasha: 真的3星了
Tasha: Really, 3 stars already?
Nicous: 真的 恭喜你
Nicous: Really, congratulations!
Nicous: 而你是我真正的
Nicous: And you are my true...
Tasha: 好这个感觉金铲铲
Tasha: Alright, this feels like a golden shovel.
Tasha: 就是比云顶容易追出来啊
Tasha: It's easier to chase in this game than in TFT.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha: 哎呀刚刚把装备人全卖了
Tasha: Ah, I just sold all my equipped characters.
Tasha: 现在搞一搞
Tasha: Now let's do something.
Tasha: 你看
Tasha: Look.
Tasha:  哎
Tasha: Oh.
Tasha: 他怎么上不上去装备了
Tasha: Why isn't he equipping the gear?
Nicous: 靠你上你给的是那个哎
Nicous: Come on, you're giving him that, right?